hello and welcome to the chichi science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about cellular reprogramming by
synthetic biology
so basically i'm going to continue with
what i was talking about in my previous
video
where i told you how epigenetic editing
can be achieved
by using the site-specific specificity
of crispr cast 9
to target the complex to different
regions of dna
and combining that with the fusion of
cas9 to different
epigenetic modifying domains that can
add or remove
methylation or acetylation groups to
different histone or dna
sites and that this has implications for
gene expression
so in this video we'll look at an
alternative way in which gene expression
can be modulated
also by using crispr cast 9 but this
time
instead of modifying the epigenetic
marks this approach works by fusing cast
9
to different transcription factor
domains and so this leads to the
generation of so-called
synthetic transcription factors pretty
cool
and what's even cooler is that this
approach has been used
to activate genes within fibroblast
cells to convert them back to
so-called pluripotent cells thereby
achieving cellular reprogramming
turning one cell into a different cell
state by using these crispr
transcriptional engineering approaches
so first i'll briefly introduce you to
these tools
and then we'll talk about cellular
reprogramming why it's useful
and then how these tools were used to
achieve cellular reprogramming
so as with the epig name editing
approaches these transcriptional
modifiers
also work by using dead cas9 that is a
cast 9 protein that has been mutated
such that it doesn't cut dna but it
retains the ability
to get directed to dna sites through its
guide rna
dna interaction and so if you want to
activate a gene
the sites chosen based on previous work
seem to be regions near to the
transcriptional start site
so that's the region of dna that's
upstream of the
gene itself and so this is the region
where the transcriptional complex will
assemble
and then plow through the dna sequence
to actually transcribe
the gene and the reason that these
crispr mediated approaches
are more desirable than alternative
protein mechanisms
is due to the fact that the crispr cas9
complex
recognizes its site by rna dna
interactions which are much easier to
reprogram
and to multiplex within a cell than
using these protein-based approaches
and so now that we've recruited cast 9
how is gene activation actually achieved
well as with the epigenome editing there
have been a variety of different methods
developed
but a lot of them seem to depend on
fusing cas9
to a protein known as php16 and so this
protein
is a transcription factor taken from the
herpes simplex
virus and this transcription factor can
directly interact with some mammalian
transcription factors
and also the rna polymerase too which is
the polymerase that
carries out transcription and hence gene
activation and this is illustrated very
nicely in these different figures here
where you can see different alternative
versions of targeted gene activation
strategies
and this one called sun tag is
particularly interesting because we'll
come back to it a little bit later
and this is interesting because you can
see there's multiple well
multimers of vp16 which can generate
more potent
transcriptional activation and so a
generic term that you may come across
for these different tools are crispr a
for crispr activation or crispr on for
any turning gene expression on i guess
and so the alternatives to these
applications
are crispr interferent mechanisms ways
in which you can mediate gene silencing
and so these are known as crisper eye
and so in a similar manner dead cast 9
is also used
that is also targeted upstream of a gene
around the transcriptional start sites
but the key difference this time is that
cast 9 is fused to transcriptional
domains that seem to interfere with
transcription
and most commonly as you can see in this
figure here
is the the so-called crowd domain
standing for cruple associated box
is fused to cast nine and so if using
these different domains to the dead cast
9
has been shown to reduce the
transcriptional output of many genes by
around 80
but interestingly with both the crispr a
and the crispr eye mechanisms
there always seems to be quite a bit of
variability in their effect
in terms of either activating or
inhibiting gene expression
respectively and so this could be due to
the locus site
the gene of interest or the cell state
and understanding these different
differences
and why there seems to be so much
variability will really help
the use of these tools in the future and
speaking of uses of these tools we'll
now take a look at how the crispr
activation system has been used to
achieve
cellular reprogramming and so cellular
reprogramming
is typically thought to define the
process of converting a differentiated
cell type
for example a fibroblast cell and
converting it back to so-called
pluripotent stem cells
and so these are cells that then have
the capability of differentiating
into different types of cells and so the
reason that cellular reprogramming
is of great interest is firstly because
it can
help us to understand disease processes
whereby you can take
cells from a patient such as blood or
skin cells which are easy to get hold of
convert them back to pluripotent stem
cells and then
differentiate them into other cell types
such as neurons that
are much harder to obviously get from a
patient and you can use that to study
diseases secondly it's just useful to
understand cellular plasticity and
understand what makes a cell type a cell
type
and then lastly of interest are
regenerative medicine approaches
whereby cellular reprogramming could
either be used for cellular replacements
or by infive reprogramming and i
spoke about an inferior reprogramming
technique that was used in mice
at the end of last year by the david
sinclair lab whereby they were able to
restore fission in old mice
and so typically the generation of these
pluripotent stem cells
is achieved by expressing the so-called
yamanaka factors
that are transcription factors that can
alter the cell state and convert that
cell back
to its de-differentiated form however as
of most things in medicine
there are two key priorities one that
it's safe and second that it's
efficient and well effective as well and
in the case
of cellular reprogramming it has been
seen previously that it's quite an
inefficient process
and part of that's due to our lack of
understanding of the epigenetic changes
that occur
when one cell goes back to a stem cell
and along with the fact that in some of
these mechanisms
not all of the cells get the same dose
of these different
yamanaka factors expressed and so there
ends up being variability
or well heterogeneity within the
cellular population
in terms of the cells that can actually
be reprogrammed
back to the pluripotent stem cell states
anyway that felt like a long-winded way
of me trying to say that there's some
interesting work being done on cellular
reprogramming
but of relevance to this video is the
fact that cellular reprogramming has
been achieved by using these synthetic
transcriptional activators
and i think that's pretty cool and so
the general theory behind these
approaches
is that instead of delivering the genes
that encode the different
transcription factors or other factors
that can achieve the reprogramming
instead you supply the cas9 complex
along with the guide rna to target them
upstream of the different genes that
encode these different
reprogramming factors for example in
this 2018 study
they used a variation of this crispr
suntag approach
to activate endogenous expression of
oct4
and sucks ii to yerinaka factors in
mouse fibroblast cells
to achieve reprogramming to pluripotency
and intriguingly in these small cells
they found that just targeting
socks too and activating sox2 expression
was sufficient to remodel the cells
since it enables the induction of other
pure potent genes
and establish the pluripotency network
and so that's great news for
mouse cellular reprogramming as it seems
like you can simplify the process
but what about in terms of cellular
reprogramming in human cells
well a study came out later in 2018 that
also achieved
reprogramming this time of primary human
skin fibroblasts
into induced pluripotent stem cells by
using this crispr activation approach
however for human cells it seems at the
moment that more genes are needed to be
activated to achieve
sufficient efficiency and establish
pluripotency in
human cells compared to mouth cells and
so all in all the use of synthetic
transcription factors
to achieve cellular reprogramming seems
like a pretty cool approach
especially if it can also simplify the
process of reprogramming
by exploiting the fact that multiplexing
can occur in this case
just by having additional guide rnas as
opposed to
having multiple genes for different
transcription factors
i did instead as delivery approaches is
still one of the major challenges
in terms of cellular reprogramming well
along with efficiency as well
and so i hope this video has given you
some insight into some cool biochemistry
and synthetic biology in terms of being
able to have control over the regulation
of gene expression
in part due to the example i gave of
cellular reprogramming
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters
and thank you for listening